[Musique]
oui vivement par un autre film si c'est
mélissa mollen dupuis alors on
recommence la chronique l'automne est
arrivé même si on a l'impression qu'on
est en plein dans l'été j'avais pris des
vacances de mes vacances pour parler de
la visite du pape d'ailleurs visite
historique je pense ne serait ce que
dans le traitement médiatique qu'on a
fait de la nouvelle on a eu beaucoup de
perspectives autochtone que ce soit ceux
qui étaient contents de la visite du
pape ce qui était vraiment pas contents
qu'il soit là et aussi une analyse des
enjeux par rapport à des communautés qui
sont très croyante d'autres qui ne le
sont pas je pense que la perspective du
point de vue des communautés autochtones
de la visite du pape a été vraiment mis
de l'avant c'est encore à perfectionner
mais jamais
de céder colonise en une nuit mais ça a
été vraiment transformateurs par rapport
à la visite que je me rappelle mon en
1984 quand le pape jean paul ii était
venu maison qu'on nous avait sortis pour
une danse ou un chant puis ça a été tout
alors là on parlait des enjeux on parle
de la guérison on parlait des choix
politiques des choix religieux qui avait
été fait pour les communautés
autochtones il un pack ou si des crimes
qu'ils avaient été commis par des
représentants de l'église catholique sur
des membres des communautés autochtones
dans les pensionnats
donc ça a été un gros été un été très lo
je pense était très émotionnel mais j'ai
pu retourner en repos et comme ça
pouvoir revenir beaucoup plus reposer
parce que c'est pas le seul enjeu dont
on va parler à l'automne je pense juste
campan en termes d' excuses au fait que
ça chine vador a reçu des excuses de
l'académie pour son traitement
lorsqu'elle avait reçu ou plutôt refusé
l'oscar du meilleur acteur pour marlon
brando à cause du traitement que les
états unis et aussi le cinéma américain
avait fait des premiers peuples s'est
arrêtée très intense surtout que ça se
passe en même temps que le stand off de
wounded knee il faut se rappeler que ça
avait été vraiment frais
risqué pour sa chine parce que même john
wayne avait voulu lui casser la figure
derrière à st il faut se rappeler que
c'était vraiment un moment très tendues
encore avec les communautés autochtones
et une invisibilité incroyable de nos
enjeux donc ça va remonter le moral
d'être au bund et demi mais ça avait
quand même amené comment où je pourrai
mise au ban de sachets en fait il ya eu
des excuses qui se sont fait donc
excuses du pape excuses de l'académie
beaucoup de gens doivent s'excuser
traitement qui était fait des
communautés autochtones dans les
dernières décennies même cycle cependant
des transformations aussi très puissante
vous vous rappelez qu'on a eu 20 ans
général autochtone on a eu des
représentants autochtones à tous les
niveaux mais je dois avouer que pour moi
quelqu'un qui a utilisé en droit la
dernière nomination convient d'avoir
c'est la nomination d'une chef de la
cour suprême du jeune chef d'une juge de
la cour suprême
madame obame samhain c'est un rôle
incroyablement important incroyablement
transformateurs et puissant pour une
femme autochtone parce que vous vous
rappelez que tout ce qui est en lien
avec les droits autochtones les traiter
tout ce qui touche au droit selon la
constitution c'est du niveau fédéral et
s'est débattue en cour suprême donc
qu'une femme autochtone une personne qui
vient justement du milieu autochtone
mais qui a étudié en droit et peut aller
prendre des décisions qui vont être
transformatrices pour les communautés
soient dans cette position là c'est
énorme c'est quelque chose vraiment où
est ce qu'on peut le voir plus comme un
rôle transformateurs qu'un euro
peut-être des fois décoratif donc moi je
trouve sérieusement il faut garder
l'oeil ouvert par rapport à la
nomination suivent justement les enjeux
des cour suprême parce qu'elles sont
transformatrices au sein des communautés
d'octobre mais c'est pas les seules
nouvelles j'ai tellement de choses à
dire les appellations ljb étude de m ça
va être maintenant de sj bits et qu plus
une transformation de la nomination de
sergio kün lille en avant de la
représentation de la bi spiritualité des
peuples autochtones au canada qu'est-ce
que mystique et la transformation et des
relations qu'on est un conte de vue à
l'eau au printemps par exemple avec la
relation du festival de la chanson de
granby avec samia qui ont des
transformatrices et on revient avec la
fin de l'été ou est-ce que là on va là
on fait un atelier pour les
professionnels du milieu de la chanson
et du spectacle pour inclure plus de
langue autochtone transformation
beaucoup de choses à la rentrée j'ai
beaucoup de choses à boire mais des
enjeux qui finissent plus de se dire est
de transformer d'esprit et aussi la
relation sociale du canada et du québec
alors n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer une
question n'hésitez pas surtout à
partager cette chronique je vous avais
un bon début de saison et je vais être
content de pouvoir analyser et partager
mon opinion sur des enjeux tout au cours
de l'année alors qu'on menait encore au
rendez-vous et gsm